thank you to curiosity stream for
sponsoring this video hi there today we
are going to take another look at some
examples from the indian j ee advanced
exams specifically we're going to look
at problems that have got to do with
electric field and flux now this problem
that you're looking at right now is from
the 2018 paper - and it's from question
three of the physics section
specifically what we're looking at here
is that we have an infinitely long thin
non conducting wire which is parallel to
the z axis and carries a uniform line
charge density of lambda it Pierce's
into a thin non conducting spherical
shell of radius R in such a way that the
arc PQ subtends an angle of 120 degrees
at the center the permittivity of free
space is epsilon nought which of the
following statements are true so Part A
asks us to basically find the electric
flux through the shell and asks us if
it's the square root of 3 R lambda over
epsilon naught now the electric flux is
the rate of flow of electric field
through a given area and usually we find
the electric flux through something
called Gauss's law so if we are to
denote our electric flux with this
symbol then what Gauss's law states is
that the total electric flux out of a
closed surface is equal to the charge
enclosed divided by the permittivity so
in this case that's it's not if we
wanted to write this in integral form it
would be a line integral and then we
would have a electric field dot product
with a change in the area so these are
vectors here and this means that if
there's an angle between the electric
field and the area that it's passing
through you will
by a cosine of theta where theta is that
angle for this problem though I think we
can just use this form of Gauss's law so
what we want to start off by finding is
indeed the charge enclosed in our
surface so our seroquel shell will be
our Gaussian surface and we want to find
the total charge inside of there now the
total charge is coming from the section
PQ of our charged wire so I'm going to
call that distance PQ D and the total
charge that is enclosed will be found by
multiplying D by lambda because this is
the density of charge along the line per
unit area so let's have a look at this
triangle and we can actually find out
what D is using some trigonometry so if
we cut this angle in half it's going to
be 60 degrees on each side that's our
there and we can see that sine of 60
degrees is going to be equal to the
opposite over the hypotenuse so our
opposite side will be this distance here
which will be 1/2 D or D over 2 and it
will be that divided by the hypotenuse
which in this case is R so to rearrange
that for an expression for D we have D
is 2 sine of 60 degrees and if we wanted
to find our Q we just times that all by
lambda now if you can have a look here
to find our flux we will just take this
line that we've found and divide it by
its lon naught but that wouldn't give us
this answer here and it wouldn't give us
the other option that they're presenting
which is in Part C here so what we
actually need to do to be able to verify
this answer is to convert sine of 60
degrees and
an exact amount so I'm going to draw a
triangle that's going to help us do that
I'm going to draw an equilateral
triangle and as best I can
which means that all of the sides are
the same length if that's true then all
of the angles will be 60 degrees and
like I said all the sides will be the
same length so they could be any length
we'll set them equal to two so every
side has a length of two now this
triangle if we were to cut it in half
there well within that was 30 degrees on
the civil part and the length of this
line down the center would be the square
root of three that's because this
adjacent side down here would be equal
to one now if I'm looking at this
triangle we can see sine of 60 is going
to be the opposite over the hypotenuse
sine of 60 can be written as square root
of three over two that's it as an exact
value so let's go back over and write
out our flux it is going to be two
lambda times sine of 60 which is this
all of that divided by epsilon naught
all right so we do that our twos cancel
and what we end up with is exactly this
amount we get our flux is square root of
three lambda over the permittivity
all right so Part A is a correct answer
here by the same argument C is not going
to be correct because it can't be both a
and C at the same time all right let's
look at B the Z component of the
electric field is zero at all the points
on the surface of the shell
well that is actually going to be true
because the electric field that comes
out of this charge wire here is going to
come out radially that means that in the
Z direction which is up-and-down there
aren't going to be any components of the
electric field so this one is correct
that the Z component will be zero
all right so let's look at D the
electric field is normal to the surface
of the shell at all points well what I
just said was that out of this line here
the electric field is always going to be
radial so if its radial out of here it
might be perpendicular to the shell but
at points here as the shells curving
it's not always going to be normal so
it's not always going to be
perpendicular so I'm gonna say that D is
not true that's all for that question
hope there aren't any mistakes I have
made a few mistakes in my previous
videos and people have pointed them out
in the comments so thank you for that
but hopefully no more mistakes
exams love throwing we are little flux
problems at us and all kinds of crazy
geometries and so I guess the more we
practice the more we're going to be able
to do in the pressure of an exam
situation so let's have a look at one
other problem so this is what we're
dealing with for our next question it's
from the 2017 paper it's from paper 2
and it's question 10 of the physics
section we have a point charge Q place
just outside an imaginary hemispherical
surface of radius R and they're asking
which of the following statements are
correct a that the electric flux passing
through the curved surface of the
hemisphere is this value here now one
trick that we're going to use to find
the electric flux in this problem is to
note that because the point charge is
actually outside of our surface the net
flux is going to be zero that's because
any flux that enters through the top
surface through the curved part is also
going to exit out through this disc on
the bottom so I'll write that down here
that the net flux is going to be equal
to zero
that means that we can equate the curved
surface flux or anything entering the
surface will denote that as flux C for
curved will be equal to the negative of
all the flux that leaves the surface
through the disc on the bottom so that's
flux of the disc now cushion a is asking
us only about the flux through the
curved surface it would be a lot harder
to find that though because we'd have to
integrate over this Hemisphere what
we're going to instead do is find the
flux of the disc take the negative of
that value and that should give us the
flux of the curved surface so how are we
going to find flux well we can use
Gauss's law again but this time in
integral form so we're going to have the
electric field cosine of theta da so
this is essentially a dot product
between the electric field and the area
that it's passing through so the
electric field will come out of this
source charge it moves away from
positive charges and towards negative
ones so this is our electric field then
this here is our angle theta this is
just for the disc and we're going to
integrate over the area of the disc so
I'm going to sit this distance here to
be little R the radius of the disc where
the electric field is passing through
and we're going to integrate over that
entire bottom area so a general form of
the electric field is going to be 1 over
4 pi it's on naught now this is
Coulomb's constant and that's going to
be multiplied by Q which is our source
charge over the distance squared this is
the distance from the charge to the
surface so in our case we can find out
the distance it's going to be this
hypotenuse of the triangle here we can
find that through Pythagoras
and if we square it this is going to be
equal to Coulomb's constant times Q over
big R squared plus little R squared now
we also are going to want to find an
expression for cosine of theta and again
we can find that from pythagoras or trig
here in this triangle cosine of theta is
the adjacent over the hypotenuse the
hypotenuse was that distance so we'll
have this expression here I'm going to
grab another piece of paper to write
down expression after the flux because I
think we're going to need a little bit
of extra room yes okay what have we got
flux of the disc is going to be the
integral of e so I'm going to write down
this here times cosine of theta
time's the a so this is going to be
integrating over the entire disk if we
treat each element of the integral as a
rim on the disk we could have two pi
ah so that's each little ring at each
different radius going outwards and then
that's going to be D over the entire
disk this is the integral we're going to
solve and its limits are going to be
from 0 to big R the radius so that's
when it's all the way at the perimeter
there let's just focus on this integral
now we're going to start by throwing all
of our constants out the front so I've
got the Coulomb's constant you all so
big R and our 2pi will come over here
what we have left with is this right
here ok so we're going to take a gulp of
air and do a little substitution to
integrate this our substitution is going
to be that U is equal to this down here
which means that D u dr would be to our
meaning that d u is 2 r dr now we can
spot an r dr and our integral here so we
can replace that with d u over 2 and
let's go through i'm not going to write
out the constants each step i'm going to
refer to them as a mess of constants and
let's do the substitution
let's think about what our new limits
are going to be if little R is zero you
will be big R squared and if this is our
we're going to have U is 2 squared doing
this integral here which is a reasonably
easy one we get don't forget our mess of
constants minus 1 over square root of U
we're going to have some twos that
cancel during that integral from our
limits let's compute that limit so we're
going to have minus 1 over 2 that's
going to be equal to all of our
constants I'll bring them back over here
the PI's cancelled and a mess of
constants times this which will become 1
over R 1 minus 1 over root 2 ok looking
at that these hours are going to cancel
and what did we actually want to figure
out what we just calculated was the flux
of the disk which means that if we
wanted the flux of the curved surface we
just need to stick a negative sign in
front of this and actually what we would
get is the answer they have here so a is
a correct solution let's look at Part B
the total flux through the curved and
flat surfaces is this value
well we already knew and used the fact
that the total flux net flux is going to
be 0 because the charge is outside the
surface so B is not correct our Part C
the component of the electric field
normal to the flat surface is constant
over the surface alright so how do we
find the component of the electric field
that is norm
to the flat surface we want to take this
Victor and ice essentially make it go
straight up and down so we want to take
our electric field that we have already
we've been dealing with and then one of
times it by cosine theta that would give
us the electric field that is nor Yin if
we were to do that we would take this
value right here our e and times it by
this value right here R cosine theta I
can write that out for you and any way
you look at that right there
we still have a dependence on little R
which is the radius so this is not going
to be constant over the flat surface
because the little radius is going to be
changing over the flat surface so this
value is not constant and that's going
to be incorrect Part D the circumference
of the flat surface is an equipotential
so you know when little R is equal to
the radius all the way around that
circumference all those points are the
same distance from our point charge so
if we were to look at our electric field
little R would be equal to big R and
this would just be 2 R squared down the
bottom here and that would be constant
all around that point they're all the
same distance away and that's all it
took so yes D will be correct and so
there we go we've solved another flux
problem just like that working through
problems like this and getting through
the academic side of science can really
start to suck me enjoyment out of the
subject if you're looking for a way to
renew some of your motivation then you
could check out this video sponsor
curiosity stream curiosity stream have
tons of documentaries and nonfiction
titles that will help remind you why
learning is
and why the study is worth it I've just
started a series called digits hosted by
Derek Muller from veritasium and he
takes us on a deep dive of the Internet
if you go along to curiosity stream
slash Tibby's and use the code to be
stirring sign up then the first month is
free so thank you to curiosity streams
for supporting my channel and thank you
for watching
you